when we look at the medium of exchange
the money you know we went from shells
to Gold to paper money representing gold
to paper money kind of representing gold
to paper money that's now tied to oil uh
ever since the US broker to deal with
Saudi Arabia to only sell its oil for US
Dollars and since everyone needs oil
that maintained the US dollar as the
reserve currency and we call this the
Petro dollar
I wanted to play a clip from a 2006 Ron
Paul speech on the house floor called
the end of the dollar hemony which you
reference in the book Let's Roll that
clip and I have a question about it for
you after all these many years of great
success our dollar dominance is coming
to an end it has been said rightly that
he who holds the gold makes the rules
that general rule has held fast
throughout the ages when gold was used
in the rules protected honest Commerce
productive Nations Thrive today the
principles are the same but the process
is quite different gold is no longer a
currency of the realm paper is the truth
now is he who prints the money makes the
rules at least for the time being
although gold is not used the goals are
the same compel foreign countries to
produce and subsidize the country with
milit AR superiority and control over
the monetary printing
presses since printing paper money is
nothing short of counterfeiting the
issuer of the international currency
must always be the country with the
military might to guarantee control over
the system it is now common knowledge
that the immediate reaction of the
administration after 911 revolved around
how they could con uh connect Saddam
Hussein to the
attack to justify an invasion and
overthrow of his government it's not
likely that maintaining dollar Supremacy
was the only motivating factor for the
war against Iraq nor for agitating
against Iran though the real reasons for
going to war are complex we now know the
reasons given before the war started
like the presence of weapons of mass
destruction and Saddam Hussein's
connection to 911 were
false what did you find compelling or
Illuminating about this speech so what I
find interesting is that the US has a
pretty aggressive history of going after
countries that um sell oil uh in
non-dollar currencies um you know
there's a lot of dictators in the world
and we don't really uh go after them uh
some of them even actually do have
weapons of mass destruction to to some
some degree at least and we just don't
really do much other than sanction them
and stuff uh but the ones where we tend
to have a more aggressive role are ones
that try to sell outside of the dollar
based system and so you know on some
sense the dollar Network effect is self-
sustaining I mean when it's TI when it's
tied to the largest economy that has an
open Capital Market um uh it's got a
very large existing debt base around the
world and debt represents demand for
currency it's contractual demand for
currency so you have a built-in
inflexible demand Source um these are
all kind of existing Network effect
supports of the dollar but it's they
still feed the network effect from time
to time especially in the 70s is when
they kind of uh kind of resurrected it
from having broken the bretonwood system
and some of these more recent ones the
reason I find this clip interesting is
that it basically shows that the list of
reasons that were given uh to invade
Iraq uh and take some of these other
actions were
unjustified and therefore it basically
argues that it had something to do with
trying to maintain the the existing
money system something that you you hear
from many Libertarians especially fans
of Ron Paul and ending the FED is that
once it's all about the money printer
and it it the creation of money gets so
centralized that that fuels War uh you
lay that out in detail using World War I
and Britain as an example how might
things have gone differently I know
counterfactuals are hard but can you
imagine what a different situation it
might have been if Fiat money had not
come into
existence around World War
I so I think that it's not that fiat
currency came and existing around world
I I think it's actually kind of the
opposite World War I part was a World
War because that was kind of the first
major war where it this this world now
existed this telecommunication enhanced
gold standard system could be readily
rug pulled so PRI prior to that point
whenever a country wanted to debase its
current so it wants to go to war taxes
are unpopular it's hard to tell someone
we have to raise your taxes to go kill
these people on this other continent you
know it's it's it's if you're being
invaded it's one thing but if you're
going to go invade others or do things
like that it's hard to sell that uh and
so rulers have historically turned to
the basement uh but the basement is
actually a pretty slow process with
coinage um you have to physically pull
the money in with taxes or other methods
remelt it into these you know debased
forms making use of the fact that you
can get more coins with that uh and so
it takes time to to pull that in remelt
it and then uh try to do it in such a
way that's not super obvious and it just
kind of you just kind of boil the Frog
slowly so to speak um
what made this world different is that
with everybody putting their money in
Banks um and Banks then became big
honeypots right so instead of going to
get everyone's gold a country could be
like well there's like you know kind of
10 banks in the country and we can just
we just with a stroke of a pen we can be
like okay so all of that has to be
deposited at the central bank and you're
all going to use the same Ledger now
it's just very easy to Central once
something becomes centralized it's easy
for it to be centrally controlled as
well um and so in that era where
everybody's Gold's in the banking system
the banking system is centralized and
basically government Central Bank have
most of the gold in their
control um or even just on member banks
but they know where it is and they can
easily just uh create rules about who
can you know redeem it or if they have
to turn it over physically things like
that once that's all in place literally
a stroke of a pen can just say well all
those Bank claims you have are now cut
in half relative to Gold overnight uh
it's a much faster debasement process uh
you can even debase foreign holders of
your currency and bonds very easily um
so basically it's the the the the speed
and the power with which you can rug
pull people uh to allocate that value
towards war is significantly enhanced
and so I think if you were to rerun the
opening of World War I before this in
this Technologies wasn't around yet it's
unclear that it would have spread nearly
as wide as it did because you you know
the the the number of entities that got
in at the size they did was in largest
part due to that printing printing press
um and that's something that it's you
know it's hard to say what the world
would have looked like uh had that not
happened but I do think that it's not a
coincidence that they were that they
were somewhat conjoined in that way hey
thanks for watching that clip from my
conversation with Lynn Alden about her
new book broken money you can watch
another clip right here or the full
conversation over here